hey folks
it's q a time back here on the dark
horse podcast live stream number 26 with
dr heather
heing and dr brett weinstein that's us
all right shall we should we q a yeah
let's q a we're going to start with five
um that we missed from last time we
missed a number of them
in the middle due to a technical glitch
uh so we're just gonna
jump into five before we
embark on the ones from the previous
live stream today
and uh and then technical glitch as
opposed to
emotional glitch is that what you're
getting at yeah at the point that zach
and i both were pointing fingers at each
other we thought it was an emotional
glitch but it turned out to be a
technical glitch
and not not user error in either of our
parts all right at least that's the
conclusion we've arrived at
all right um so in q for q a
number 25 we got this question hi
bretton heather i'm an 8th grade teacher
searching for advice to pass out to my
students who are incredibly weary of the
world they're growing up in
especially now what advice would you
give
now in part i wanted to just flag this
as something that you know we've been
you know we've got we've got a whole
chapter on schools
and another one on childhood in the book
that we're writing um but this is this
is a
a critical question and maybe you want
to riff for just a minute yeah
i mean i think really for all of us who
are
searching for a silver lining here
you're looking at me like i'm about to
joke no i'm going to do my best okay
to actually give some sort of useful
solace
i think really actually this is true and
this is what i tell myself and it's what
i would tell my kids if they asked and
that's what i would tell your kids if
they asked
the potential for
change is directly correlated to
the level of disturbance
and so to the extent that we find
ourselves facing
very uncertain things in the near future
it is also um something that will tend
to accompany a transition to something
better
so in evolutionary terms this is an
adaptive valley
whether there's a peak on the other side
i sure hope there is but um
the potential for change is here as is
the uncertainty
all right it's uh it's the beginning
it's the beginning of an excellent
answer i think
no i think we we we need years
to provide the complete excellent answer
that's you've provided
directions to the foothill we need years
we have hours
next question again from number 25
rather than today drugs are always a
controversial subject
some are considered medicines others
controlled substances i think if it
helps someone it's considered
a medicine period what are your thoughts
about marijuana fungi
and psychedelics hashtag legalize nature
so this is something that we have
addressed um a few times but uh because
it came
at a high money value from someone who
clearly hasn't heard us talk
at all about this i thought we'd give it
a minute or two sure
so i would i would say number one thing
is these things can be
very useful they can be uh a
tremendous relief they can provide
insight i would say number one thing
though
is don't treat them as recreational
they are very serious and it doesn't
mean you shouldn't have a great time and
have a smile on your face
as you do but treating them as frivolous
is a mistake they're powerful enough to
do
great things and they are powerful
enough to mess you up
if you don't
i would say curate your experience such
that it stands a good chance
of being productive but
if you think these things aren't for you
they probably aren't if you think they
might be for you
engage cautiously think carefully about
the damage you may do to your health
you know there's a difference between
the molecule and the way it's delivered
in the case of marijuana you can mess up
your lungs if you
smoke it so maybe consider doing it some
other way which is now much easier than
it once was
um but a cautious
positive view of these substances and
their potential
but advice to to engage them carefully
yeah and i guess i would just add the
hashtag that the
person who asked the question ends with
legalized nature
is an apt one uh that at the point that
something
has even if it's been derived uh from a
plant uh
but synthesized in a lab such that it
has no
resemblance at all to uh the plant or
animal or more often fungus from which
it derived
the more likely it is to do you harm and
to have very little resemblance
uh to uh the state that it might have
produced
uh if you were imbibing it from the
organism in which it came so
um you know you can use that very broad
rubric that sort of rule of thumb to say
okay you know avoid
avoid those things which require that
you stick a needle in your arm or
or start powder up your nose uh and um
know
that there is both long evolutionary
relationship between humans and many of
these
species and maybe more importantly
there is long cultural history not for
most of us within whatever sort of
mutt-like aggregate culture that we come
from
but for many many cultures have
a relationship with entheogens in
particular and
learning from what other people have
learned from
their use of hallucinogenic plants and
fungus mostly
is uh is an important first step and it
can be
incredibly valuable to do so yourself
yeah but don't lick a toad without
consent
i would say written consent is probably
safest
so let me just say that on the very
first the
very first time that i had students in
the tropics before
uh we were at evergreen i had just been
hired on to
teach a tropical animal behavior class
at a little field station
in panama i heard tell that
some of my students were licking frogs
and i had to give them a hard time
because these were not even the right
toads oh goodness
they were not the right toads at all and
i you know i thought
you know if if you're going to seek
these sorts of experiences out at least
at least get the organisms right yeah
yeah yeah
looking frogs and taking names yeah
okay so just a huge oh
this comment meant a tremendous amount
to me so i just want
i wanted to share it just a huge thank
you i'm a conservative christian and i
can't tell you how much i value your
podcast as a gut check against my echo
chamber
because you both seem like
intellectually honest patriots
thank you really really appreciate that
yeah and uh we obviously don't know much
about you beyond your comment but uh
right back at you
yeah uh have you guys actually been to
chaz chop
that's what it says zack zack's laughing
in the other room have you guys actually
been to chaz chop
yankee marshall a youtuber has done a
few live streams there he's showing
something completely different
uh than what we're seeing on social
media outlets who recommend coming to
the footage
so i have not yet but i thought it was
worth mentioning that here do you know
of
of this youtube channel i've seen some i
don't know
that one in particular what i would say
though hey i've certainly considered it
um it's not especially close to us so
it's not like
you know if we lived in seattle i would
have been there for sure but um
the problem is there may be i'm sure
there is and i've seen
lots of footage that suggests reasonable
stuff happening
all sorts of moments in the chats chat
but you know we've got
three is it now four shootings we've got
video of uh white people excluding
other white people from lawns so that
the experience of
uh black people can be centered on a
lawn i mean
you know the point is look is there
insanity in the chat shop
there is insanity in the chat shop is
there reasonableness
probably a lot of it but the fact that
there is enough insanity that is easily
easily found and filmed
tells you something about how reasonable
the
whole experiment is also i would point
to
the uh the fact
of them excluding the police
from a shooting at the same time that
they demanded
the paramedics come in you can't run a
society this way
right either you're prepared to have the
police and the paramedics there
or you're deciding to provide those
services yourself and so anyway this is
a
at some level this is an absurd exercise
and it has revealed exactly what many of
us told you it would
yeah they have at least done us the
service of allowing
us to call them the jazz job so that's
something right
okay final uh comment from
the live stream 25 rather than today's
uh and a number of people pointed this
out um that
actually while we were on air last time
apparently jonathan herzog just
announced his support for darkhorse duo
he's
uh running for a congressional seat in
new york
district 10 apparently so that's
interesting
and important and good yes there's his
support
for the dark horse duo plan which
will probably soon get an official name
in the neighborhood of unity ticket
um but we are also supportive of
jonathan herzog's support of the dark
horse duo plan
it seems only fair um and supportive of
jonathan hurts i don't mean to joke
you know it helps pass the time
all right um moving on to um
to questions from the last hour thank
you
this is just a comment thank you the idw
has been a godsend for me be that as it
may it doesn't look good for the home
team
yeah what is the significance of singing
in humans why do we have two distinct
registers
why can we do this and then there's a
link which we didn't have time to look
at so i'm not sure
what exactly the question is asking and
why is it so emotionally stimulating
love from scotland um
so i i actually i'm not sure exactly
what the two distinct registers oh i
know it's referring to either male and
female are an octave apart is that but
that
but but we but you know we we obviously
have overlapping ranges
it's it's it's a rare moment rare women
who have no overlapping ranges
we have overlapping ranges um but that's
but there's nothing
else around two distinct registers i
thought it might be
like a focal fry or like i don't think
so i mean i
i take it to be male and female um so
let's put it this way
you've asked a very deep question which
would require a book to answer
but let me simplify it a little bit
one the distinction between singing and
music
is a new one so it would have been true
until very recently until the invention
of musical instruments
that music was inherently vocal and in
general
contained lyrics it was inherently
lyrical almost all the time it would
also be true
that all that basically every intact
human would have a direct relationship
with music they wouldn't just consume it
they would participate
in the creation of it and music wasn't
static
it used to be that even the songs that
your tribe
sung were songs that changed over time
right so even the standards were never
the same twice and then
at some point the invention of the
player piano songs start to be the same
twice and then that gets really bad in
the era of recorded music oh but it's
far
before that at the point that music is
being written down in the baroque era
there's that you have repeated
music oh you have repetition you've
always had that
but the idea of exact repetition
i think i think that at the point that
the baroque era was upon us or maybe
even earlier i'd known far less about
what came before the baroque but
um you know we we know what could have
been and
was being played over and over and over
again from
boy bach would have been 1600s i think
um so you know repetition has been going
on for
you know as long as the written word so
you think music has been broke
far longer than i think it has but uh i
was walking into that one
yeah you did you set yourself up um but
so let's put it this way there is
something to be said about the player
piano being the first point at which the
song might be
the same twice but i agree with you you
know written music
does invite the attempt to produce the
same
song twice and a conductor might
do the same rendition twice so anyway
they'd be very close
but this is all of it is a departure
from the natural state of music
which would almost always have been
lyrical and would always have been vocal
until
i don't know the invention of the first
musical instrument so the point is
the uh answer to the question is really
going to be found in what is the
evolutionary advantage of
uh vocal music right
and i'm going to leave you hanging there
but i would say
one of the things you need to recognize
in order to address this puzzle
is the close connection that music has
to the production
of language and uh
anyway i have a long-standing hypothesis
here which needs to be explored at some
point
yeah we should we should devote an hour
or more uh to this at some point but
um this one thing that just occurred to
me
which had never really occurred to me
before is that i mean
as as you know i was i was trained in
classical piano played for
you know practice for a couple hours a
day for many years during my my
childhood
and um so the baroque period
sort of happened and i don't know a lot
about you know what exactly happened
before them but baroque
was during in part the era of clavichord
and harpsichord where there wasn't
dynamic
possibility you did you didn't have the
ability
as you did with the piano the piano
forte which was the thing that that
changed about the keyboard was now you
could play softly or loudly right
um and it was
very much uh as i understand it you know
the baroque
led to the classical period and in both
of those both of those cases
yes the musician who was playing the
music could change
what was being played but you really
weren't supposed to stray
at least for you know someone playing
individual piano music from the baroque
you know
like bach and then the classical period
you know beethoven um
brahms haydn etc were very much supposed
to be played as they were written
whereas then you move into the romantic
period in the 19th century like chopin
and tchaikovsky and such
and you suddenly get a lot more freedom
again you know sometimes they'd stuff so
many notes into a single measure that
you could just you know do kind of
whatever you want
want it dynamically and metrically and
it was almost like a return
to what music was what music was before
um before i feel like the sort of the
drum the you know the the metronomic
enforcement
of things from the baroque period
happened
i don't know i don't know what all that
was about like why that happened
um well i mean i think you're on the
right track in the sense that the
elaborateness of the instruments and the
you know in the
case of the harpsichord in particular
the mechanistic nature of the
instruments
um invites a more mechanistic playing
style so you think the technology may
have driven
the musical style yeah anyway none of
which
almost um is is about singing which is
its own
you know it's it is the original
instrument of course
and and amazing um okay
next question jury nullification we
lawyers
those who are even taught the doctrine
at all are taught to ignore it
how long can this pandora's box be kept
closed do we pry the litter jar by even
asking the question
well it's been asked um you know and
this isn't the first time if you haven't
uh heard us talk about it i know eric
has talked about it
jury nullification for those of you who
don't know what it is is
the ability of a jury to decide
that even though so courts do two things
findings of fact and findings of law
so in a court you establish what took
place and then you decide whether it was
a violation
of the law the jury has the ability
the capacity to neutralize
the law part in other words it can
decide that you did something
and it can reason that
even though it was a violation of the
law
that it is going to rule as if it wasn't
thereby
freeing you right so this is in some
sense a protection that exists in the
law
because we can all imagine extenuating
circumstances
uh in which one in which a miscarriage
of justice would occur by the
application of the law so the fact that
a jury could potentially do that
is a protection however basically my
understanding is that judges
instruct juries that they do not have
this right and the hope is that the
right will effectively never be
exercised because the mayhem that could
arise from its exercise
is massive
and in this case we have the near
certainty
that many things that are violations of
the law and severe ones
will not be penalized because we are
told that
certain people are uh in debt and others
uh
are uh in surplus and therefore
you know it's one more place where
reparations can happen your
right to violate the law may go up if
you have certain demographic markers
that's a very frightening prospect
even more frightening is the prospect of
the other thing which maybe it has a
name
must have a name that i just don't know
which is
where somebody who has not violated the
law is going to be convicted
because of some sense that they are
morally deserving of being punished
and um i am very afraid that both of
these processes
are very proactive no it's not proactive
what is it it's like activist
yeah jury activism or it's legislative
jury activists i don't know what you
would call it but the idea that juries
will effectively be empowered to punish
people who haven't done anything wrong i
mean for one thing we're seeing the
equivalent of that without a jury
in these cases where people are getting
fired not having done anything wrong
well you know you know much more about
the law than i do but given that it's
findings of facts and findings of law
that are the two things
um that a jury is supposed to be
deliberating on
don't findings of fact have to come
before findings of
of law and if if you if the findings of
fact
say there is nothing that happened here
do you even get to move on to the
findings of law
oh no it's a well right i'm not an
expert here either but yes
effectively the facts either have to
support the possibility that there was a
violation of law or not so you
a jury that wanted to could neutralize
this in either place it can decide that
a fact
that fabric could it could it could come
to an untrue conclusion
on the findings of fact front thus
opening up the possibility of a
of a punitive uh decision over in
findings of law territory
right and of course the judge is
supposed to be the
uh fail-safe mechanism you know the
judge that finds the jury engaged in
deliberations that it shouldn't can
declare a mistrial but
you know where in the system is anybody
immunized from being accused of racial
wrongdoing
in the modern era so everybody is going
to start recognizing
um that they might need to do what the
mob demands and that is
i mean as i keep saying it's the
uninvention of america
and wow are we in danger if this keeps
going
yeah next question can the emotion of
awe
unite us back again
um that'd be great and i like the idea
i'm a little bit concerned that
something about modernity
has made us hard to impress yeah right
that we are
all privy to the most extreme uh
demonstrations of capacity and beauty
and
you know we've all been transported to
the
most marvelous beach on earth you know
which has further more than been
photoshopped
right right so yeah we we all imagine
that the perfect
beautiful person and the perfect
beautiful place and the perfect
beautiful everything
is not only um something we've already
experienced even if we haven't but that
it's actually
better than it is such that when we do
experience true
awesomeness in our lives we often don't
recognize it as such because it doesn't
live up to the unphotoshopped
uh unperfected version of itself yep
that said i do think that there are
things that will galvanize us or could
galvanize us
and um one of them
i am hoping is the possibility
that there is a way out of this that
will in fact make us feel good about
ourselves again
and i am a little bit concerned that
unfortunately i find myself in
trying to write what that would be like
it is very hard for me to deal with the
word
hope now because i feel that um
the obama administration was
such a disappointment in terms of what
it accomplished
that um many of us felt his hope
we we signed on and then we're quickly
disappointed it has almost poisoned the
concept of hope
and um that leaves us grasping for
synonyms that are never as good this is
interesting i didn't know you were you
were thinking on this and i knew
i know what you're trying to write right
now but um i actually went looking
specifically i was i was looking for
something to read at the end of the last
hour that would be hopeful
rather than you know rather than so much
else and i must have you know a pile of
10 books downstairs all of which i think
are extraordinary and i couldn't find
anything and the closest i came
actually um but i don't i don't have
something to read from it
um was from joseph campbell you know i
went to
the the hero with a thousand faces um in
part because we were talking about
um one of the things we were talking
about between
this last live stream and the last one
was was the hero's journey and
um trying to
reveal to people that
they can take hold of that for
themselves and
that uh in trying to face this thing
down
it is not sufficient to take individual
action and yet
it is in many cases the only thing that
is possible
and well um i would like to propose
something that we didn't
get to in depth today was a deeper
exploration
of what what you do um when
it comes knocking and maybe i mean maybe
we want to do that
next time yeah i think we want to do it
next time and we want to
take the time to do it do it right but
there is something
i do have the sense that the world is a
much bigger place
than it was and the hero's journey is
simultaneously
it contains a great deal of truth but it
also may be at the wrong scale
and so the question is can we figure out
how to scale it up
to a world with seven and a half billion
people on it
that is simultaneously in crisis and if
you think about that
it's a frightening question but it's
also kind of a delightful opportunity
and so maybe that's where we are as
we're trying to bootstrap
the the new twist on the hero's journey
because we need it yeah
next question while there are many
domestic issues going on i'm concerned
that international issues are being
ignored at our risk
would you please have general robert
spalding retired on the podcast
he wrote a very revealing book recently
about the chinese communist party
i'd look at it um it's i agree
i think we are missing the international
component of this as we are hobbling
ourselves at home
our enemies are licking their chops yeah
there's no question about that
and the fact that uh half the country
has the sense that anything that comes
out of the president's mouth is
inherently wrong and ludicrous uh
means that for him to have for trump to
have said anything
about chinese involvement uh
in this virus means that half of the
country now has a knee-jerk reaction to
ignoring that is a very possibility it's
a great example
right we can't even talk about the facts
of what this virus is and where it came
from because trump has
taken a position and that causes others
to be completely unable to hear
um even factual information yeah it's
anti-intellectual
yep why are yawns contagious in quotes
are they similarly contagious in other
primates do you think ideas expressed
before yawn might piggyback on the yawn
to be spread more effectively in a group
oh wow
that's so interesting uh i don't know i
never thought of that
well i don't know about the last piece
yeah i did have a
a kind of a riff on yawns but it's been
years and i don't have it at the
tip of my tongue um there is i think
something about state of mind
and that effectively yawns are something
that spreads because it's like a
feeling of security sufficient that
sleep would be acceptable
and so you can imagine a you know pride
that could be an indicator of trust even
yeah it's an indicator of i perceive
that this is secure
uh and that spreads to the group and so
anyway that raises all kinds of
questions and it maybe predicts
certain things about the way it
functions but it is fascinating and yes
it is contagious
in multiple different kinds of creatures
now i wondered at the time that i was
working on this whether it was
contagious between types of creatures
which would be very interesting yeah um
and i don't i don't remember whether
there's any evidence yeah i have never
seen an analysis of that anecdotally it
doesn't really look like it
um you know when when we've been
watching you know wild primates for
instance
um and they they go on a yawning bout it
doesn't seem to track into
us or other things or you know when our
cats start yawning
um it spreads through them but doesn't
spread to the dog
yes but that's you know that's anecdote
i am
i would put money on but not a lot of
money on the idea that actually that has
not been looked at
yeah i'd cross species contagion of
yawning but within species contagion yes
yeah and at least some so at least some
other primates and
seems to be at least domestic um
companions it's interesting how
widespread it is though which suggests
one of two things
it's all it's only mammals still
widespread
yeah right but the question is is it
convergently widespread or is it ancient
and we've all inherited it from some
yawning ancestor yawning tree shrew
yeah something like that um
okay next question do we need to make it
costly for every coward that throws
their towel in with either extreme
especially in media academics and power
let everyone
know now we will not forget reason will
prevail we will remember those who
betrayed it
we will not forgive so that's a yep
that's a good question it's just a
little hard to read
do we need to make it costly yes yeah
and in fact that's why we have this
term and why we use it what term coward
um so uh if you look back in the various
tapes of us talking
we have spoken frequently about the
epidemic of cowardice yep
that is a message to those who did not
stand up
and to those who are looking at them to
figure out what to do
that that is not the honorable position
and
the problem is what you cannot do is
tell people
stand up and it will be safe so the fact
is the cowardice is really about
something
but yeah turning up the heat on
cowardice
is the right move you have to do it
honorably but
especially what i would say is actually
the cowardice that i am
least sympathetic with is
cowardice of people who can afford to do
something else the cowardice for example
at the head of the democratic party is
despicable
and it is um i can't say it's
criminally treason but it is in effect
treasonous because we are going to
destroy
the nation uh in an effort to let those
people not
say what they should full well
understand so yes turn up the heat
i would say though your lasts i i'm not
seeing it but
we will not forgive we'll remember those
who betrayed we will not forgive
i would not say that i i would say we
don't know where this comes out and
frankly
if we don't forgive anybody who has made
an error
in this era there's going to be very few
left yeah
so we will not forget we will remember
but we will not forgive is maybe a
bridge too far yep i think it is
just about half an hour okay we're going
to get through at least a
few more here front thing we started
with some questions from last time
um do you follow slate star codex
that's actually that's not quite spelled
right i think
it's called slate what is it star codex
yeah star right
um any thoughts in the new york times
doxing scott alexander and the resulting
deletion of his blog
it's abhorrent new york times [ __ ] up
again sorry we're not supposed to do
that
new york times no it's it's despicable
and first of all you know what
hey we've got a podcast there are
thousands of people watching there's
also a petition
many of us have signed it that you
should sign
to to ask the new york times
not to dox scott alexander as if that
needs to be stated but apparently in
this era it does
so let's just say um i was thrown
because there's an extra
letter in there that caused me to
misremember so it is slate star codex
it's a long-standing independent blog
on all manner of rich and dense
and uh intriguing intellectual topics
um that is written under a pseudonym to
protect the identity
of the author um who it turns out is a
clinical psychologist
who for whom if his identity were
suddenly to be revealed
uh the damage yes to him for sure
but especially to the mental health of
all of his patients who would suddenly
be faced with knowing all of this
backstory on their therapist
would be extraordinary and to what end
the new york times doesn't even have a
justification for
um for threatening to reveal his
identity there's there's no journalistic
justification
at all and i we can't point you to slate
star codex now because
the person who writes is scott alexander
has now taken it down it's
it's really horrifying actually you go
there like you know and like
it's just not here let's put it this way
here
um the coup has knocked a
singular property off the map in one
move
yep right so this is telling you what
this horizontal
uh coup is going to do to us right to be
able to take out
that node in one go is just
stunning is it slate star codec i can't
remember now yeah i know i now can't
remember
a thousand times but uh anyway exactly
i'm sure
uh your search engine well actually i
can find it
codec so it is right it's just not start
yeah
okay um does mark antony always win over
brutus
does the dark horse duo need a marc
antony and or dogma to succeed
um no for so i don't think anything is
necessary i think we're in
a brand new spot and people know
we need help and so anything that checks
the boxes
of does it solve the problem does it
address my concerns
does it put me in jeopardy is capable of
doing the trick so
narratively speaking what is the best
way to get there that's a
that's a question and i don't know the
answer to it but
uh i don't think
i don't think this is a matter of um
hitting the narrative perfectly i think
this is a matter of the system is so
broken and the solution it's handed us
is so inadequate and the danger is so
great that
um many people have years to hear if we
can
deliver them a version of the plan that
is
clear
heather in one of the earlier live
streams you mentioned that vitamin d
supplementation isn't the same as
getting vitamin d from sunlight
could you elaborate on this thanks and
much love to you both
the i can't say a tremendous amount
about vitamin d
in particular but the logic is is this
uh that our modern uh reductionist
approach to health tends to focus on
finding isolating quantifying
and then prescribing in the form of an
actual prescription or just
over-the-counter
pills the thing that is now imagined to
be what is keeping you from health and
this is um it is it is reductionism that
is
the flaw here and also a kind of um
scientism sensulata wherein um
a scientific approach allowed for the
isolation and
naming and quantification and synthesis
of this thing
but no one took a step back and looked
at the whole system which is
inherently complex and said okay what is
the value of this within the system
and does it have interplay with other
parts and of course it does
so we have any number of examples in
which something has been isolated
and then it turns out that that is not
the thing that was actually necessary in
the way that we thought it was
but it was something that was easily
easily found easily named easily pointed
to
and then turns out in isolation doesn't
do nearly as much
good so it's possible that some of these
will actually work
in isolation it's possible that vitamin
d supplementation
is just as good as as uh
as getting it through your skin but i
would i would put the chances of that
close to zero
um just as uh well
well i was gonna say we have a lot of
these cases where
the problem is you're using the logic
of simple systems on a complex system
and
so for example um why am i blanking on
the
name for the loss of calcium from bones
with age
osteoporosis osteoporosis right in the
case of osteoporosis well there's not
enough calcium in the bones
obviously give the person calcium they
don't metabolize it why would that be
well you're dealing with a complex
system and the whole reason that the
calcium is lost from the bones in the
first place isn't what you think it is
so the simple fact of dumping calcium on
the system doesn't work so
uh this is this is a perfect and pure
example
osteoporosis is caused by lack of
calcium therefore just add calcium
right no it's an evolved system it's not
going to work that way will occasionally
a system work that simply
maybe sure but the vast majority of
these things
aren't going to work with simple
supplementation there's an excellent
book
which we referred to in in our book
which um is reminiscent
which points out that some of the error
in this kind of thinking
um and i've forgotten the author but
it's called the tyranny of metrics
uh and it's it's a short book it's
really extraordinary it points to how
this kind of pseudonumerate thinking
has uh managed to finagle its way into
medicine into education
into all sorts of places where it has no
business being
yep and uh in this case you know
we moved indoors that blocked the sun
we produce vitamin d through contact
with the sun through a kind of
photosynthesis
and supplementing is not
an excellent way to replace it now there
are modes of supplementation that do
seem to work that involve things like
uh fish oil um but these are cultures
that have a long history of having had
to supplement because of very cold
winters for example so
the the simple lesson very very high
latitude so like cod
cod liver oil turns out to be
a way to get the vitamin the equivalent
of the vitamin d that you need
which was a discovery by uh
scandinavians and vikings
um not because they knew they were
looking for that thing but because those
people who ate a lot of that
food survived better right they did and
they may have carried some mythology
along with i'm sure they did
what it was but um but the simple thing
is when you disrupt
living systems you invite consequences
you don't see because these systems are
complex and there are things you don't
understand about how they work
so the idea that you can just simply
blaze in there and remedy them with
the obvious technological fix often
doesn't work so
yeah go in the sun avoid sunscreen
don't get a sunburn by taking little
breaks in the shade
that would be i think the best most
useful advice
yep given the status of things is there
any genuine recourse aside from
networking and massing militias
i like being hopeful as much as the next
guy but we know what this is and where
it goes for the helpless
um well yeah there are
it kind of depends where where in
civilization you stand whether you have
useful things to do
i think there are important plays to
make that could take this disaster and
turn it into
something useful but i don't know any of
them that don't involve
an outbreak of leadership in which
reason becomes a capacity of this
movement
so are you hoping for an epidemic of
leadership
i don't know that i'd call it an
epidemic
yes i am hoping to see leadership emerge
and
i am despairing of the fact that it does
not seem to be doing so but
uh yeah i really hope it doesn't the
militia
answer how can this be anything but a
disaster
it's going to be civil war and i don't
even know you know at least in the case
of the first civil war
there was a geographic distinction so
that you know there were at least
outcomes that made some sense i don't
know what outcome emerges out of a civil
civil war here that makes any sense
who do you divide from what you know or
is it just a bloodletting in which case
can we not figure out how to avoid doing
that
i'm stunned that we are here even though
i have long thought it possible
i'm stunned that it has happened it's
still surprising when it shows up yeah
uh seeing strong selection pressure for
traditional
okay let me see this is written sort of
telegraphically
seeing strong selection pressure for
traditional gender roles in antiquity
compensation for high child mortality
and low life expectancy etc
i look for the same regarding
anti-homosexual norms to no result
what am i missing can you parse that
um no i'm gonna try again i can't quite
parse it i'm just gonna read it as
straight as i can okay
seeing strong selection pressure for
traditional norms
start over again seeing strong selection
pressure for traditional gender roles in
antiquity
parentheses compensation for high child
mortality and low life expectancy etc
and friends i look for the same
regarding anti-homosexual norms
to no result what am i missing
okay i'm beginning to get what that
question means i think it has to do
with homosexuality removing people from
the breeding population in a way that
mortality would be expected to
right and so this person is looking for
um some sort of cultural compensation i
think in some sense this is missing
um this is going
we've been threatening for so long to
rent a hall and and
uh unleash a person is trying to get you
to give a
30-second teaser okay the teaser is look
um homosexuals were always there hiding
in plain sight
and the role that they were playing
was an important one so
the reason that you do not see the
expected
compensatory cultural mechanisms is that
what has happened is a disruption of the
normal
phenomenon of homosexuality as it exists
in
culture after culture so some at some
point
it will be possible to rent a hall and i
would like to rent a hall and i would
like to deploy something other than a
cryptic
hint at what might be
in that uh logical quadrant but
all right we're not renting all today
nope
okay uh this next one's just a comment i
tuned in live when possible always
listen to youtube uploads thank you for
keeping true dialogue and dialectic
alive
thank you hey heather and brett from
your first hand experience do you guys
think the end game and ultimate goal of
the critical race theory and affiliated
studies and movements is some variant of
african-american independence
i think there's a there's a faction that
may be trying for that but i don't think
it's
it's actually dominant i think it's more
about amassing power
and wielding power over all of us
yeah i mean i don't even know you know
i've heard of
voluntary separatist movements yeah um
but again i mean how do we
even if you thought this divorce was
smart and i think it's stupid but
if you thought this divorce was smart
what does it look like
right we're not geographically separable
frankly we're not even
separable as people because the
intermixing has
been uh extreme you know to our credit
yeah but i mean this person isn't saying
could we do it this is the end game and
the ultimate goal
you know do some people over in critical
race theory
and affiliated studies um hold that as a
goal
i think some do i think you know they're
desperately confused
about what what it means um
but i think that it is it is a faction
factional perspective yeah i think it's
mostly mythological but
anyway yes there will be those
in the movement but in some sense the
movement is
a set of incoherent demands and yeah
let's see what sticks is kind of the
approach
yeah okay just a couple more here and
then we'll go into the next
uh next live stream
there is a time asymmetry in reasoning
with spurious arguments by answering
madness with reason
are we putting ourselves at a game
theoretic disadvantage maoists use dirty
tactics
will we be out competed by playing fair
um great question yeah i don't think
there
is a mechanism to win
by playing deceitfully i think it will
break down into
madness more quickly and that in some
sense
the only option is
to respond to the madness with reason
and then to try to amplify
the protection
for those who recognize the reason and
abandon
the absurdity so there is tactical stuff
to be done but
it does not involve um coming up with
our own kafka traps
that's just not going to work yeah okay
so we're just gonna do the last two at
the
20-ish dollar level before switching
over okay
and there's a couple in the tens that i
really wanted to get to so maybe we'll
start there
next time this is my first time
listening live thank you so much for
doing these
have you heard the news coming out of
the uk regarding dexamethasone as a
treatment for covet-19 do you have any
thoughts on this from a biological
perspective
i have sort of vague glimmerings of this
and i don't really know
much don't know yet more and so no
thoughts yet
presumably we will have more at some
point if it if it
lives as a as a news item it doesn't
just disappear because it turned out to
be false and
so many things in the cove 19 era are
happening
okay uh i like the hashtag darkhorse duo
plan
but worry that many sympathetic voters
would still vote for their preferred
lesser evil to avoid the spoiler effect
do you think a vote pairing app or
website could be useful in mitigating
this
well let me tell you yes i know you i
knew you went to get to that one yeah
we have put a lot of thought into the
spoiler effect
uh issue and what i can say is as we
reveal
the plan in all of its glory uh this
week
you will see that there is a fail-safe
built into the plan
so that it cannot act as a spoiler
this is one of two major objections that
people
have and we have a structural fix so
on the one hand i don't think you need
an app to deal with that the failsafe
does not require an app
that said i do believe there are things
that an app could be
very useful for in this plan and then
frankly building out the plan so that
the proof of concept can extend to other
offices not just the office of president
so anyway i'm very keen on the idea of a
sophisticated app that will form
the basis of a
retooling of our democratic process to
make it work according to
the values spelled out in the
constitution which i should point out
does not mention parties okay
starting at we hope the first question
that came in
in the current live stream we have a
comment keep up the good work everyone
chip in a few dollars
thank you next question can black trans
women get more intersectional points for
converting to islam
yes yes i think they can we'll see that
coming soon
all right yeah uh being wired this is
from echo
being wired to like the smell of people
genetically related to us
seems to give incentive to socialize and
reproduce inside lineage that is
preserve and gain immunity many people
move from ancestors niches
is this still relevant and then a
follow-up question if we all wear maoist
perfume while we get along
um so let's just say this is a tough
question
right there's a question about what
society we would like
and one thing that people advocate for
is a society in which we actually do
stop taking racial distinctions
seriously and we blend into each other
and that's great
the problem is there may be genetic
reasons
that your genome doesn't prefer that
which are not actually relevant to
your person and what it would want and
then there may be reasons that your
genome doesn't want it because it's
actually
um in some way costly so let me just say
you have different um things in tension
on the one hand you have attention
towards
breeding with people who are closer to
you in all probability and that does not
have to be genetic it can be transmitted
culturally as well
and then you have a force pulling you
away from breeding with
people who are too close and then you
have another factor which i would say
is and again this can be kinetic it can
function culturally or a combination of
the two which is hybrid vigor
so to the extent that um
one has certain things that function
very well
in one population and other things that
function very well in another population
a hybrid may carry the values that exist
in both those populations
to one individual so it's a very
complicated
puzzle and i don't think we have a deep
understanding of all of the nuances here
but let's just say we are constantly
being jerked around
by our genomes we are being jerked
around in our actual interests we're
being jerked around in genetic interest
that we should not honor and then we are
being pulled in directions that we don't
understand because they may
uh contain values that um we are unaware
of
so let's not oversimplify it is really i
guess what i'm getting at
are we memeing ourselves into oblivion
yes what mimetic
next question what medic should be
stressed to self-correct
um i mean the problem stop it yes
the problem is we have
because memes which
came into existence with richard dawkins
chapter 11
of the self gene in 1976
that's where the concept came from the
concept was a scientific concept
until it became an internet concept that
then got kind of trivialized by
what we all call memes which are cute
little
gifs and things that have text
associated with them or whatever
and the problem is in some sense there's
a lot of stuff that actually at a
technical level
is clearly memetic these podcasts are
clearly mimetic
and so there's a whole landscape of
podcasts that are actually
trying to sort out difficult issues
rigorously at
uh you know in a long form so um
that is us struggling through a memetic
landscape
towards reason and it may be the answer
to the insanity that arises in a world
of people
um you know hurling uh trivial memes at
each other
so yes something in the pneumatic
landscape is probably the answer
good you're up next as well what are the
primary very significant disagreements
that you and sam harris have
um you know there are a few apparently
one are they growing well i think i
think
a lot of things uh trace themselves to a
few roots
one has to do with determinism and
whether this could be a fully
deterministic universe
another one has to do with free will and
i think that
the free will discussion is contingent
on my being
right about the uh the determinism
question
if it's a deterministic universe i don't
even know what free will would mean
if it is a non-deterministic universe at
some level then free will is possible
sam says it isn't possible
yeah so i mean there are philosophical
positions that allow for one without the
other
it seems incoherent to me but i've seen
i've seen it written
yes you've seen it written and if it was
in a deterministic universe i don't know
what that would be
so anyway there's that and then there's
this question of pan psychism which i
don't know where he falls out today
on pan psychism but pan psychism the
idea that consciousness
because it is um seemingly resistant to
rigorous explanation by standard means
must therefore
in some sense be written into the
material that the universe is
constructed
of which i find preposterous may even
predate matter
right so anyway i would say those are um
those are the biggies and the funny
thing is
in some sense i don't think almost
anything important depends on these
things because
frankly sam he's very careful to argue
that regardless of whether or not he's
right you need to behave in an honorable
and ethical and moral way
right sam lives like a guy
who doesn't uh believe in these things
and he would probably tell you that so
oh yeah um
so in any case i there there are some
disagreements they're probably worth
sorting out because these are actually
important philosophical questions
but probably nothing depends on it which
is why sam and i get along
in spite of our differences that's right
uh this from holly mathnerd why is
transgender identity even without
transition
celebrated but trans-racial identity is
considered an appalling appropriation of
oppression not your own
thank you holly uh it's a
that's a great question well and in fact
we i've now forgotten
the woman's name was it no it's a
different
we had it we had an academic famously
cancelled
over making exactly remember who it was
it might have been duvall anyway
so somebody made this argument in an
academic paper
um i mean you know didn't make the
argument pro
or khan but basically said is this
analogous and
a firestorm erupted so let's put it this
way
the reason that we don't notice that
inconsistency is because we have
completely given up on the idea of
consistent
yeah consistency as a virtue yeah we've
our people wolf is back yes our people
wolf is back now
wagging carrying a large donut around
off my chair
um yeah it's it's totally incoherent and
consistent and it and it reveals the
hypocrisy
uh of the of the field the scholarship
uh and uh if you could point that out to
an individual
it reveals maybe not their hypocrisy but
if they don't think on it and get back
to you and say i
see that i have to accept both of these
or neither of these
as um in order to remain consistent
uh then it suggests very strongly that
they are not working from first
principles but working from
received wisdom yep and if you can just
do a thought experiment here too
it's possible oh no no okay well
try not to get us in too much hot water
but it is possible
that a person could transition
from white to black so long as they took
up an aggressively
i don't want to say pro-black so i don't
think this movement is pro-black but
an officially sanctioned pro-black
position but if you were to imagine
somebody
transitioning sean king style
to black and taking up a skeptical
position of the movement
it would not function which tells you
something about where we are
that what is permitted is no longer
about logic at all
it's about um what you plan to do having
done so and um anyway
that's not how logic works right you
will be required to adopt these ideas
if and only if uh you also agree with
this over here otherwise you are
prohibited from doing so yep
uh have you guys oh have you guys
considered any question submission
systems besides super chat i vote with
my wallet and i can't stand the thought
of youtube taking a 35
cut yeah it's egregious isn't it i'm a
software developer i would be happy to
build you a custom one
well kyle um let us see if we can figure
out how to be in touch with you because
yeah so zach is saving that for us and
uh that would be
that would be great because uh being
more free from youtube would be terrific
and obviously um if you guys are
donating to us it would be great if we
got more of that money and uh youtube
got less they're getting plenty as it is
they've softy monetized now your
conversation with eric yeah and your
conversation with yuri degan yep um john
mcwhorter has remained unsoft to
monetize that might look racist if they
were to
have to monetize that one so they didn't
i actually think they did it for they
softly monetized almost all of them
reflexively and then i have to appeal
and the thing is
there is no so we're basically i mean
there's very little money coming in from
ads so most of it's from super chat
at their mercy yeah we're at their mercy
which you know it's just
absurd there's no there's nothing to
appeal to there's no
analog of a court there's nothing it's
just it's a company town there's all
these these people who
uh were indoctrinated
in uh the latter day adherence from the
schools of ed
there you go yeah so uh yeah we will uh
we'll follow up with you thank you next
question i'm an author
the children's book industry has become
highly political and activists are
greatly influencing who publishes what
to
various methods any suggestions on how
to push back without getting canceled
thanks yeah we talked about this
uh a little bit on one of our earlier
q as
i haven't noticed children's literature
although directly
although i recently uh spent some time
at powell's
in the ya section the young young adult
section and it's
it's devastatingly bad um how to push
back
um you know there there are little
glimmerings of hope
some places at some publishing houses
with imprint
imprints possibly trying to um
create a buffer for authors um i don't
know if any of that is happening in
children's literature
or why a literature and it also um
that's not of course the first thing
that would be authors run into the first
thing you run into is the agencies
literary agencies
and when i went looking for literary
agencies
boy three three and a half years ago for
uh science fiction i was amazed then
at how many code words how many woken
intersectionalist
code words there were in almost every
agency that i looked at so it's
it is i don't even know even if the
publishers
even if some publishers get smart to
this how do you
do an end run around agents given that
most publishers won't even look at a
proposal from you if you don't have an
agent
i think it's the wrong question all
right um
the fact is you have
an ideology it is logically
incoherent what are the chances
that every university in the country
would find itself enthralled to it
there's zero there are lots of us who
know what's wrong with it
so what happened power happened there is
something powerful enough
to take every university and turn it in
this direction
right that is going to be true for
were it true that there was a
publication that resisted this
completely
it would be wildly popular right because
people they don't need
yet another vox they need something that
speaks in a different voice
and so um the
fact of the absence of the alternative
view in some sort of standard form tells
you that what's really going on is
something very very powerful that is
capable of taking every property and it
will
right that's what we're facing so in
some sense
looking for a strategy how in a world
where this seems to be very widespread
do you accomplish x the point is no if
you accomplish x then you're going to
become the thing that it has to go after
in order that nobody can accomplish
x so in some sense we have to fight this
thing
um with a an understanding that it is in
some sense
a uh a spreading ideology
that infects everything a horizontal
revolution
and that the idea how do you how could
you construct a platform that wouldn't
have this happen if you did
they would have to find a way in and
they will so
um trying to navigate it as an
individual
effectively hopeless you can leap off
into i mean this podcast is
an independent voice and it's an
independent voice because
um because the tools to simply put
something into the world and have you
directly reach it um exist
but we still you know we're still you
know at the whim of
youtube to some degree right and i was
going to say
uh within the book publishing industry
um
being able to self-publish became a
thing
that has not nearly as much negative
connotation
now as it did 30 years ago 50 years ago
it was would have been impossible
really a hundred years ago or so um but
i think independent publishers are still
basically dependent on amazon
right i think that that then is the
arbiter of whether or not you're woke
enough now
and i see for instance that and this is
not a self-published book but
abigail schreier's new book uh which is
on
uh trans uh rights activists
specifically in the contagion that's
uh happening to teenage girls uh
has been somehow vanished from from
amazon and you know she's she's got a
publisher it's not i don't
remember apologies abigail if you're
watching i don't remember if it's one of
the you know the big
four or five publishers but it's a it's
it's an extant
reputable publisher that's been around
for a while so it's not just her
fighting amazon but um still they're
losing
so it's it is possible
and yet we're all still going through
some
some portal that does have an ability at
any moment
to say actually no i don't actually like
what you're saying
it's choke points is the problem it will
ultimately come down to
google is a choke point amazon is a
choke point
your isp is a choke point the credit
cards are choke points
and this thing is in all of those places
so it cannot resist now there is a
question about why
a podcast like this is tolerated right
and i
what we don't know is if you duplicated
this
and you tried it if you didn't have um
our following and our friends the things
that we have accumulated in the time
since evergreen
blew up you might be able to uh drive us
extinct
without anybody making a fuss and it may
be that the thing that allows us to say
what we say is the fact that the cost of
um
taking us off these platforms is too
high it's
it would put them in two awkward
positions so i don't know the answer to
that question
i certainly do frequently feel twitter's
thumb on the scale i feel google's thumb
on the scale
and um there's no telling i mean
the slate star codex example is a case
where
something the the coup went too far it
went after a property that actually a
lot of
important people were paying attention
to yeah and so now they've got an
awkward situation on their hands
um but that you know do you want to live
in a world where the only people who can
say
true things are people for whom it
becomes really awkward when you toss
them off the platform or
docks them or you know put them through
a struggle session yeah you don't want
to live in that world you want to live
in a world where we are all protected
from struggle sessions because struggle
sessions are wrong
okay we'll get through a couple more of
these um
can we please address can we please
address the gender gap in college
education and graduation rates
what does it mean for our nation's
workforce and for family life
so the gender gap that the person is
referring to obviously is the inverse of
one usually invoked
that we have um gosh i think it may be
closing in on 60 40.
60 of college
actual undergrads and i think graduates
are now female
and the gap is growing and
it is certainly it is skewed differently
into different
degrees across different disciplines but
it is real
this is something that christina hoff
summers has been on
for decades at this point i think it may
be something that we talked about with
her and peter bogosian on stage
when we were on stage with her here in
portland a couple years ago and that's
um that's up on that's online we can
link to it here i think i think that we
talked about this a little bit
in that um in that event um
but what does it mean for the nation's
workforce and for family life it's going
to be deeply destructive of it
because you've got more men than women
without college degrees going forward
and in the past having a college degree
was the thing that you needed
to move into the middle class the
college degrees are less and less
valuable now because
of what we've already been talking about
with regard to what's going on in the
academy
but they still have this sort of badge
of success
about them many women are going to only
be
looking for mates who have an equivalent
or higher
level of that kind of badge and so
there's going to be greater competition
for men which is going to cause greater
failure of families as men see that they
can choose
among the women who are valuing them
it's it's chaos across the board
and there's no reason to expect that
this
there's no reason to think this is in
any way good just celebrate
i feel like some people are celebrating
this but what is certainly happening
even if that's not true
um no one talks about it yeah i mean we
we have on a few occasions
but the only gender gaps that we are
allowed to talk about
are the ones in which women are are
still lagging
uh even even when all of the trend lines
look like um look like those
those gaps are going to even out very
soon there's something
petty and deeply nihilistic about what
we are seeing and they just simply go
after
that which works and um
anyway yeah i mean it's
boy i i hope there's nothing to but
maybe there is something to the
observation
that higher ed is becoming a cesspool of
irrelevance
exactly as uh women are requiring more
and more power within it
um it is it is a it is a disaster i
didn't say it i'm not even sure i heard
you say it no
i guess you didn't um raz simone for
president well that was not my phrase
that was the next
question here which is president oh
president of the chump jazz
no total disaster dream overlord maybe
um you know depending well look
the thing about warlords is they would
have to duke it out so
um i'm who's who's gonna be the
competing warlord then
well that depends how you know we need
some different
autonomous zones each one will have to
have a little battle for
warlord and then as they meet we'll find
out you know i mean
you're looking i didn't hear you say it
i don't think even you said it
okay shouldn't marxism be treated the
same way nazism is treated in academia
and elsewhere
shouldn't funding violent
revolutionaries be treated the same as
funding
terrorists and those assets seized
wouldn't those two changes
end all of this no um
so first of all i hate this because i
don't want to be
defending communism
um i will make the same point that
always gets me in trouble
which is that there is a critique
inside of marxism which is not so easy
to dismiss there is a
plan which is crazy that we know doesn't
work and i would argue that actually
somehow in this discussion we are
missing the central fact which is that
the world's most boring conversation
which is about whether or not group
selection is an important evolutionary
force is the key to understanding why
marxism
when translated into communism does not
work so somehow we are going to have to
get up to speed on
why this plan every time it evolves and
it doesn't have to come from marx
you can have people reinvent the plan
and decide hey wouldn't it be cool if we
all pointed in the same direction
redistributed everything that plan is
not going to work
but um i tell you what i'll give you
something tantalizing
the body is communist
the body is communist in the following
sense um from each
according to the human body everybody
okay
this isn't a political statement you're
making no this is an anatomical
physiological statement okay
okay go from each according to his
ability to each according to his need
that's how the body works
right why does it work because all the
cells have the same genome
they have no reason to disagree over
this plan right so the point is altruism
is built into the way you structure it
why won't that work with people
because our genomes aren't the same
until your worst is not communist a tree
is communist but a forest is not
correct correct so if you understand
that
then the point is listen you communists
you've missed this important biological
fact
do you want to get us to all point in
the same direction do you want
well-being to be widely distributed
the answer to how you do that is through
enlightened self-interest and
cooperation it is possible
it is possible to build that system but
it will not be communist that's not how
you will get there that thing is
unstable
and the reason that you get
gulags and other forms of oppression
traveling in tandem with this mode is
that the
failure of it to work forces you to
re-incentivize things for people in
other words what causes people to behave
in a communist way
is the threat of death or being
imprisoned and all that stuff
we don't need to go down this road we've
discovered it already
many times over let's not rediscover it
do you want to redistribute
opportunity i'm all for redistributing
opportunity right but if you get stuck
in the redistributing wealth
conversation you're never going to get
there
right opportunity should be broadly
distributed any honest capitalist should
tell you that
right they want opportunity broadly
distributed if they're honest
because that's the way the maximum
amount of good stuff gets done
right when you have people sidelined
people who have incredible capacity and
they're sidelined cleaning somebody's
toilet
that's a waste that's somebody who might
have invented something awesome who's
doing something
that you know a robot should do right so
distributing opportunity broadly great
but let's build it on a foundation that
makes some sense and that involves
known things right cooperation that is
based on enlightened self-interest
so one of the key misunderstandings then
is
uh that the body be it a human body or a
tree's
body or whatever is effectively
communist because
all of the cells and systems in that
body have shared
fate this is the concept um that this is
maybe one of the concepts
i find most important from evolutionary
biology that they have shared fate
whereas the trees in a forest have
some shared fate but not wholly shared
fate just
as the people in a village or a town or
a nation
um cannot have fully shared fate whereas
we all of us on the planet do
yeah right so so we have we have a
planetary shared fate but that's too
big to uh to regulate at the same kind
of level that we need regulation and
good governance and effective governance
at the more local scale
but bodies can act individual human
bodies
are effectively communist in a way that
uh
that corporations and
towns cannot be because there is
incomplete shared fate
i want to add something to the mix
shared fate is very important but
frankly i'd argue
nationally we have shared fate right if
we wreck the nation
we're going to be collectively screwed
but
there are two things that work in the
body's favor
in establishing corporal communism or
whatever
you would call it one is the shared fate
um and the other is the complete absence
of conflicts of interest
i mean i i put that under shared fate
they're distinct right you can put a
bunch of people who might have conflicts
of interest
in a rowboat and they might still have
shared fate if it
goes under right but the body
by having a genome that accounts for
every
cell means that your liver is more than
happy to surrender whatever resources it
needs to to make your heart function
because it would be suicidal not to and
so
the notable exception of course being
cancer well and
cancer is basically i won't say this in
every case because there are cancers
that are contagious and things but in
general cancer if it functions the way
we think it does
is incoherent it's like renegade cells
that frankly don't have an interest in
being renegade because they create
a tumor that yes it grows but it's a
dead end
so um so yes the body has an
overwhelming
reason i mean you know the body
cooperates to get the gonads into a
position that they can actually produce
some
next generation that's that's the game
but they have every reason
your liver doesn't want to freeze out
your eyes it wants your eyes to have
everything they need to make them work
great so anyway
yes yep that's that's the analysis
that's great
um i've been consistently annoyingly
sharing the evergreen dock by mike nena
but next steps will the idw band get
back together
we need leaders but we also need
direction on how we can best support
this movement on our own
didn't your brother say he was getting
the band back together i believe i
retweeted that very thing yeah it
sounded like he was getting the band
back together
um i'm looking forward to it as i've
said elsewhere i
miss idw i think idw was
doing very important work i think it
needed to evolve into a next
phase and maybe it has and it just
hasn't been
correctly understood but i do think uh
boy it's time we're we're in such
jeopardy
and what we really need are people who
can say the difficult things and live to
tell the tale and demonstrate it and
then
it needs to spread the ability to do
that needs to spread yeah
i first learned a view on joe rogan
after our kids in catholic school
in grade eight homework asking how to
decolonize the canadian military
and grade four being told
boys have periods too i have watched and
read
all of jordan peterson eric brett etc
thank you to very much so there's not a
question there but
um yeah decolonizing the canadian
military and in grade four that's what
like a nine-year-old an eight-year-old
nine-year-old being told that boys have
periods too
hopefully hopefully what happens is all
this garbage
is gonna backfire because even kids that
young are going to begin to detect that
the adults who are talking to them have
no goddamn concept what they're talking
about
but that's i mean at best then we end up
with an entire generation
of uh traumatized children who never had
effective adults in their lives
i mean look and you know and this this
in catholic school
we're gonna we expect other kinds of
ideology perhaps to be percolating
through catholic schools
not this okay here's the thing i think
it is a mistake
to imagine that somehow we're shooting
for a world in which children are not
traumatized
we're all traumatized okay we are losing
the thread of the conversation
and the point is look trauma
in isolation is bad trauma gives rise
though
to the ability to do the extraordinary
the unusual the unexpected and so
if we could start thinking about the
fact that modernity
is actually traumatizing every child can
we
turn that trauma into something valuable
can we turn it into independence of
thought
into a high capacity i mean you know
you know the way we joke with our kids
has
trained them to spot [ __ ] right
right like it's every day it's a 24 hour
a day training
they know they know how to spot [ __ ]
and really actually some high quality
[ __ ] but
but the point is not so high quality oh
yeah you know
you got to mix it up right you don't but
in any case somehow we need
those people who get it to
understand that they have a
responsibility to convey
to indicate to kids they encounter hey
kids
you may be hearing some [ __ ] it'll
be coming from surprising places it's
not always in
advertisement sometimes you know it may
be your
your teacher and you know you'll know
the teachers who really know what
they're talking about because for one
thing
they're the ones who will entertain your
questions and give you back an answer
that sounds like an answer
that's a good way to recognize a good
teacher if your teacher punishes you for
asking questions
if they spout back something that sounds
like nonsense and you can't figure out
what they said
that might not be the best teacher
that's right
okay let's let's get one more question
we get a couple of thank yous we have a
you need more bandanas if you're
if we're going to hold up a train
station this is my contribution trains i
was thinking stagecoach
uh
okay let's do uh
two more here do you think since a lot
of this started in literature that
starting with how we view stories
might fix it i'm not sure it started in
literature i think it started in the
pseudo scholarship
but certainly it's taken over a fair bit
of literature and i do
think that taking back
myth and narrative and um
generating narratives that we can
get behind uh will be an important
part of this that we don't but one of
the things we'll probably talk about
next time
i'll just allude to a little bit here is
that um
one of one of the reasons that we in
quotes are at disadvantage
um is that there seem to be a lot of
compelling narratives in the form of
you know viscerally compelling anecdotes
on the other side and for the most part
the rejoinders that make sense
are in fact these dispassionate
careful statistics based on actually at
the population level
this is what is happening and uh
statistics are never going to be
a good rejoinder to a good story you
know humans humans operate emotionally
at the level of stories so we need to
have good stories that we can tell
so i'm going to take a slightly
different tack i i agree that this is
fundamentally important and you have
pointed to the importance of
high quality narrative many times i'm
going to argue that the
failure of narrative is one in a cluster
of failures
that are crippling our ability to
to be decent to each other and to move
forward that there is a
junk version of everything right we are
being
induced into junk narrative
because we think that the purpose of
narrative is entertainment
i'm not arguing that you shouldn't be
entertained by narrative i hope you are
but that's not its purpose
right we are being induced into a junk
version of sex because we are told
that the purpose of sex is basically
getting off
right i hope you get off but that's not
the purpose of sex
right the purpose of sex has a lot to do
with uh
bonding right we are told that the
purpose of
drugs is uh a thrill to pass the time
right escape nope these are very serious
compounds that tap into the deepest
parts of your mind
and the most important things are also
often fun
so right when you say serious just just
so you're not misunderstood here right
when you say serious you don't mean it's
going to be hard work and it's going to
feel gray and you're not going to enjoy
it
right no no the point is the fun is
nature's little reward to get you to do
the work
that's the thing the work is rewarding
it's supposed to be
but it's not the reward isn't the point
the word reward is the thing that gets
you to do the work the point is the
product of the work
and you know music again we think that
the purpose is to entertain us
we don't even realize that we've lost
track of the fact that you're not
supposed to have
your own music in your ears and
everybody is supposed to be able to pick
the thing that
you know tickles their mind just so we
are also supposed to have a shared
musical
supposed to be bringing us together and
not driving us further apart
not just bring us together but it's
supposed to be in some sense
synchronizing the way we think around
the same linguistic structures around
the same melodies
and that those are powerful and
important forces that we just unhooked
not even thinking about what we were
doing and so
um you know you got music drugs sex
all the important stuff we've been given
a junk version
and we need we need a narrative we need
to resurrect
the functional version and the product
of doing so would be a great deal more
satisfaction we are pursuing
satisfaction
directly and we are getting less and
less of it and pursuing
a higher quality interaction with each
other over these things would have
exactly the opposite impact and
um it couldn't possibly be more
important
one more question thank you guys your
perspectives have changed my mind in
many ways
so do you think life will ever go back
to what we knew
or should i start to adopt a new normal
as much as i hate that term
yeah the old normal's done i think we
know that for sure yeah it's impossible
to imagine we go back
um even if things formally went back to
allowing you to interact the way you
once did i think we're all a bit rattled
at what we've now seen
we've seen uh we've seen
a threat to our way of life and this is
true no matter who you are no matter
which side of this divide you're on
we've seen a threat to our way of life
we have seen people
open up possibilities that we didn't
realize were
near at hand and we've also seen that
things can sneak up on us
covet 19 um i
increasingly believe is a self-inflicted
wound
but to the extent that a self-inflicted
wound can
emerge from some place half a world away
and you know bring us to our knees we
should have been preparing for that all
along
it wasn't a secret that it could happen
and the fact that we didn't and the fact
that it's done this to us and the fact
that it may have unleashed the social
unrest all of these
are evidence of what it is that we're
not paying attention to
during so-called normal times so in some
ways
normal is over and that's probably a
good thing
yeah well
here we are i think we did it i think
we're there
thank you all for tuning in uh we will
be back
in all likelihood on tuesday
and tuesday we'll have our private q a
tomorrow at 11. private q a tomorrow at
11
and uh like subscribe share tell us what
you think
and uh we'll keep doing this be well
everyone
you